wir haben die schnauze voll davon und
wieder zu gucken was man alles noch an
lösungen für die probleme finden kann
sie wollen menschen retten aber es
fehlen die betten in der pandemie
kämpfen notärzte verzweifelt um plätze
für ihre patienten
mit bangen blicken beginnt ihre schicht
ist die neuro intensives zu
die mittagszeit wenn wir sehen schon
dass ein großteil der häuser doch
probleme schon wieder auf mit den
intensivbetten hat das ist natürlich
beruhigend
der erste notruf ein schlaganfall
glück im unglück diesen patient muss
eine große klinik nehmen die diagnose in
dem fall erleichtert die betten suche
weil wir dann die spezielle
fachabteilung brauchen und die auch den
patienten erst mal angucken muss bevor
sich die frage nach wie wird er waren
weiter versorgt stellt
notarzt sein heißt in diesen tagen vor
allem um betten zittern kliniken
anbetteln dabei aber trotzdem den
patienten möglichst schnell gerecht
werden der mann ist instabil leidet
möglicherweise noch an einer inneren
blutung jetzt zählt jede minute im
klinikum stuttgart warten sie derweil
auf die nächste corona patientin
abwehren was geht ist die devise das
häufig in stuttgart und der region kein
intensiv wert haben oder mal ein bett
haben sind wir in sehr engen kontakt mit
den anderen notaufnahmen und probieren
da einfach kollegial dass ein bisschen
umzuleiten nicht dass jeder sagt nein
nein nein und die rettungsdienste haben
wir den patienten jetzt auch wir kommen
eigentlich täglich an die grenzen und
jetzt war es letzte woche so dass hier
die letzte herz-lungen-maschine verbaut
haben und da denkt man schon fuß was
mache ich mit dem nächsten 40 jährigen
von ihrem vater die 28-jährige kubi
patientin ringt um luft
ja ich habe kurz mit aufgesetzten
da schon erhebliche lungen befall zu
erwarten ich würde mal mit rechnen dass
wir sie auf jeden fall aufnehmen sie ist
gott sei dank zu mindestens einmal
geimpft das hilft einfach aber auf der
anderen seite nimmt sie das kortison was
das immunsystem so ein bisschen dampf
jetzt kommt notarzt rüdiger schwager mit
dem schlaganfall patienten heißt für das
team der notaufnahme blitzschnell um
gekleidet sein
der mann in lebensgefahr darf
keinesfalls mit dem virus in berührung
kommen
je nachdem ob sich die blutung stoppen
lässt
nur dass es nur dann anstrengend weil
man weiß dass man natürlich nicht
unbedingt gern gesehen ist wenn man den
nächsten patienten reindrückt obwohl
samberg anschlag sind aber gut das ist
dann so es muss gemacht werden er checkt
noch schnell die belegung der korona
intensivstation auf der er arbeitet wenn
er nicht als notarzt unterwegs ist
dabei ein name fehlt
ja
es läuft wir eigentlich kalt
der nächste einsatz und parallel alarm
im schockraum die ärzte mussten einen
mann reanimieren jetzt wird er beatmet
wieder ein bild mehr belegt genau jetzt
sind wir bei noch einem bett für den tag
x und
der nächste herzinfarkt rollt an es ist
ein arbeiten am limit das zehrt
so langsam wirds halt auch schon
schwierig sich wieder zu motivieren die
nächste welle wieder zu nehmen und
wieder zu gucken was man alles noch an
lösungen für die probleme finden kann um
dienen die patienten versorgen kann das
geht schon an die substanz sei
irgendwo platz schaffen wie lange geht
das noch dreas dieses wort hängt wie ein
damoklesschwert über der klinik hat
jeder angst vor weil es auch eine
ethische frage ist ein stückweit
reagieren wir ja schon auch unterbewusst
herr also wo man sich schon manchmal den
ko war das gut denn jetzt nach hause zu
lassen ja das ist ja schon so eine
vorstufe der triage also wir probieren
uns einfach aufzustellen dass wir klare
linien haben und dass wir uns da ein
bisschen schützen alle betten belegt und
ausfliegen ist im akutfall keine option
ich werde ich jetzt einen patienten habe
der braucht jetzt eine versorgung dann
habe ich eine stunde zeit das irgendwie
zu organisieren und kann ich ein
flugzeug irgendeiner hamburg besorgen
das ist die große befürchtung die wir
natürlich die ganze zeit haben vor allem
jetzt noch wenn die zahlen weiter
steigen
rüdiger schwager übergibt an den
nächsten notarzt ohne dass ein notfall
passieren darf in dieser nacht im
großraum stuttgart
ja